JJ you made me a promise before you
started shooting I worked years ago on
The Simpsons and I started a tradition
then of getting the word Jubjub into the
show and then I had job job said in
various shows and movies and I begged
you to work the phrase Jubjub into the
new Star Wars film and here's what you
said on the air let's take a look I know
that if I asked you you put Jubjub into
a Star Wars movie I know you'll get it
in somehow I know that you'll does
that's gonna happen job well of Binks
yeah his brother yeah we are that was
some time ago
the film is completed did you keep your
promise you did and you got jump jump in
I did I'm told you brought an actual
clip would you like to see it no there's
no time
yes
this is fantastic
there are stories about what happened
[Music]
Jub Jub
The Voice you didn't sound in African
actual truth Jubjub is in the film Jeff
Jeff really isn't a film that was
clearly not it that's not the moment and
that's not the mom it's not Han Solo
looking right to camera
I'd say jum Jeff st. jump jump in
someone else's voice by the way is it
terrible actor who every okay okay
that's very exciting I hope that didn't
interfere with the plot most of the
story wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]